[Music]
danny's in dodge city kansas
hey danny how are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well great um i was calling to find out
last year i sold some property that i
had had for
around four years in colorado and
by the time expenses and everything were
paid out and
i walked away and put into a trust like
2.5 million dollars i hate it when that
happens
and at the time
the cpa and the lawyer that set up the
trust for me the cpa
was talking to me about like annuities
and all that and i just didn't at the
time think last year was a great time
to invest
invest it so it's just been in the bank
and now i'm starting you know i'm 51
years old starting to wonder is it time
to put that to work for me through some
passive income or something and
what other investments wonder what other
investments
me and my wife each have roth
with about 300 000 in them a piece
i have some farm ground that's worth a
half million dollars it's paid off we
have our house we owe
30 000 on
well you've done really well
congratulations yes i've done well and
this is
money that you know it's kind of just a
windfall from that in
investment well let's just think about
some basics for a second okay
if two and a half million dollars owns
almost nothing which is what it's
earning right now
uh or if it own if it earned 10
that'd be 250 000
so every year it sits there earning
nothing you're missing out on 250 000
dollars
so we need to do something with it to be
wise right okay
now and i just didn't know last year
where the market was headed
i don't care where the market is i don't
care where the market's headed on the
short term
all i care about long term because
you're not going to jump in and jump out
and jump in and jump out i'm not going
to teach you a day trade or buy bitcoin
or some kind of bull crap like that i'm
going to teach you to invest long term
that's what i do right now i buy two
things danny you can buy whatever you
want to buy but i buy two things
both of which make me more than a 10
rate of return on average some years not
some years a lot more but an average of
over 10. one is i buy a series of good
growth stock mutual funds spreading my
investments in growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
the second thing i buy is i buy real
estate that i pay cash for that is
income producing real estate
you've had pretty good luck with real
estate so you may want to consider some
of each
uh but even if you went heavy real
estate i wouldn't be mad at you for that
it's up to you which one do you want to
do but you need to put this in you know
go buy you a nice little uh office
warehouse or a strip center or an office
building or something that's producing
you know a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year for your
you know your two million dollar
investment here uh that kind of a thing
and or maybe you do a million dollar in
real estate you do a million and a half
in mutual funds i don't care but we
never do investing for the short term
that's not investing that's speculating
right we do long term you when you
bought that farm ground you didn't buy
it for what to do the next week or or
two years later you bought it for what
it'd be long term
right that's an investment mindset
investing is a mindset speculating is a
mindset so i you know get with a good
real estate agent pick you out some
income producing property or jump on
solutions dot com click on smart
investor pro
and um
sit down with one of the people that we
trust in the smart investor world that
we're not in that business but they can
help you with some mutual funds
and do some of each or all in one or all
in the other i don't care but leaving it
just sit there no an annuity no and
don't use your cpa
for financial advice they're not good at
it is there a clock on that money dave
before it like with capital gains if
he's not it's already he already paid it
he's already paid it okay it's done okay
yeah he did that's done sticking a trust
doesn't hide it from capital gains okay
so um but john i think the important
thing regardless of if it's uh 2.5
million or if it's a
100 000 you know in your 401k
you need to stop and think about what
you're not getting
by sitting there yeah there's some great
psychological research on
we underestimate what we don't get by
sitting on the sidelines we're so
terrified to risk we're so terrified to
put stuff out there we calculate that
and we over inflate that but we under
inflate what we missed by sitting on the
sidelines and i think it's the same part
of our brain that
i read one thing that said if you lose
ten dollars
a share on stock you have to make fifty
dollars
to get per share level the feeling to
level the feeling out because ten
dollars does more damage to your
psychology than a fifty dollar gain does
five to one yeah to your to your uh
does to your psychology it it you know
and so it's the same thing on that but
what we're talking about here is
financial people call it opportunity
cost yes you have the opportunity to do
this with it and i we used to do this in
an old financial peace university less
than a thousand years ago we don't do
anymore i rolled a mercedes out onto the
ta out onto the uh thing we disconnected
the battery we were inside this church
doing the video shoot right but we
rolled this mercedes out and we said
okay if you put a hundred thousand
dollars in this
in ten years
you'll have nothing right
you know or virtually nothing right if
you put a hundred thousand dollars
in a mutual fund in ten years here's
what you'll have and it's like a million
bucks right and so
[Laughter]
so even even if the market was half of
that just by parking it you're losing
out on six figures yeah so you're you
know
if you put it in the wrong thing and it
goes down
like a car or you consume it yeah
or you do nothing or sits making you
know a quarter of a percent of the
savings account you're missing
the upside so it's the by putting the
money in the mercedes you miss the
opportunity to having invested and it's
okay to buy a mercedes of course i've
got one okay there's nothing evil about
that but you need to think about when
you're doing it
that money is no longer working
yes it's now lazy money
it's it's it's depreciation or if it's
going down in value it's welfare money
right i mean it's going the wrong way
right right but it you know what you
want is you got to think about if that
money was working
breaking a sweat what would it do and
thing about money is it works 24 7. it
never gets sick it never quits
it never gets mad at covid it never it
never has a hissy fit it doesn't think
it's a snowflake it just works all the
time it's best employee you'll ever have
it just works and works and works and
works and works works but you got to put
it to work
but it because it doesn't work i've nev
i'm thinking about this out loud in real
time i i've never thought of it
i'm guessing that everybody needs to
know where they fall on that risk
continuum because i identify with that
last caller if i got a windfall my my
head i would say i don't know what to do
i'll stick it somewhere and i'd look up
in 10 years and still be there but i can
also imagine other people
would rush to just start wheeling and
dealing it and they're going to end up
losing some of it so that's the other
end you got to know where
so you know being paralysis of the
analysis
is is not good yeah and being rash and
gambling is not good right but you have
to take enough risk to not miss out on
what life has well it's almost this is
why you and i jumped out of an airplane
the other day you know you got you got
to jump you got to you know you got to
take enough risks to live that's right
and also it's good to have a former navy
seal strapped to your back so you're
probably going that's helpful you're
probably going to land right um that
yeah that's that's really good and
heading into that having a plan
man having a plan is everything i think
about all the trading guys in the
military will do so that when they hit a
chaotic situation they it just goes to
rote i'm gonna do this and then this and
then this and then this
muscle memory right so when i autopilot
if i live with the little stuff when i
get a 2.5 million win follower 25 000 or
whatever that is i i already have the
game plan for what that's gonna yeah but
that's we're gonna do that money and we
were just hanging with some seal guys
the other day and you know they were
telling us the same thing it's not
really when you hit chaos or if you hit
chaos it's just when it will that's
right and so if you've done the training
your brain is ready you're going to
autopilot when stuff goes sideways
that's right um not exactly the way they
said it but yeah when things go sideways
right and so yeah that's what separates
folks right it's true but it's the same
thing's true with money okay so
yes you should not throw money around in
something just because somebody said to
you need to understand what you put the
money in that may take a hot minute but
it doesn't take five years right and it
doesn't take you know like we you know i
took a call in the early days of the
show this guy had like he had like 20
000 bucks in rolls
and buried in his backyard in a coffee
can
and he's like so what do you think of
that
and i said i think you're losing two
thousand dollars a year how long has it
been back there ten years i said you've
lost more than the money in the can and
you ought to go check the money in the
can because paper money doesn't do real
well in moisture it might be gone by now
so you know you you do have wrists buddy
it's called rust and worms yeah and and
neighbors with a
you know a metal detector